[Music]
kimchi is Korean comfort food the zesty
blend of fermented vegetables has been
part of the Korean diet for at least
2,000 years it's so valued by Koreans
that some even have special
refrigerators for it in their homes like
fine wine kimchi must be kept at a
specific temperature to be at its best
full of stomach friendly probiotics
kimchi is believed to be good for one's
health which is why demand is on the
rise beyond Korean borders making kimchi
starts with a preparation of organically
grown vegetables there are many
different recipes for kimchi this one is
vegan and less spicy than some other
versions
the kitchen staff trims unwanted bits
from carrots and scallions
they then peel wilted leaves off of napa
cabbage which is the main ingredient in
kimchi its taste is sweeter and softer
than regular cabbage over at the scrub
station a worker claims the trimmed
vegetables under cool running water if
he misses even a speck of dirt it could
interfere with chemical reactions during
the fermentation process
this could sour the flavor of the kimchi
and spoil the batch each vegetable must
be pristine
the next member of the team shreds the
carrots using an industrial food
processor
shredded bits of carrot will ferment
quicker than big chunks scallions can't
easily be shredded so he dices them by
hand
[Music]
the kitchen staff carves the cabbage
into fairly large strips because cabbage
is thin bigger strips will ferment at
the same pace as the shredded carrots
and diced scallions the next ingredient
is ginger a spice that will add flavor
and soothe the digestive system another
worker transfers the shredded ginger to
a porous cotton bag she folds the bag a
few times to create a packet and then
places the packet under a press the
press squeezes juice from the ginger and
extracts the ginger essence while
leaving the stringy pulp behind the
worker weighs the ingredients beginning
with the shredded carrot this is the
largest ingredient after napa cabbage
she then measures the portion of
scallions that the recipe calls for she
adds a scoop of celtic sea salt and
checks the scale
other ingredients include crushed garlic
chili flakes and the ginger juice she
stirs the seasonings into the vegetables
and the ginger juice begins to saturate
the scallion and carrot pieces all the
ingredients now come together in this
mixer with a big dough hook the worker
adds the carrot and scallion blend to
the napa cabbage in the base of the
mixing bowl she activates the mixer and
the dough hook folds all the elements
together fermentation begins triggered
by the evenly distributed salt workers
then transfer the mixture to special
fermentation crocks and pack it down
to half-circles ceramic weights add
pressure to the salted ingredients
juices flow and immerse the kimchi
vegetables creating an oxygen-free
environment the salt suppresses the
growth of bad bacteria allowing the good
bacteria to flourish another worker
pours water into a moat around the lid
creating a ring of water that acts as a
kind of seal one that will keep air out
of the crock but will allow fermentation
gases to escape
one week later the kimchi is
sufficiently fermented it is now a
living food full of good bacteria a
worker packs the kimchi into jars and
weighs each container to confirm that
the amount is correct
the jars must be completely full with no
air space between the kimchi and the
lids that could compromise its shelf
life she labels the jars in shrink wraps
a plastic collar around the lid once
refrigerated kimchi can last for up to
14 months well preserved
it's practically always ready to be
served
[Music]
you
[Music]